IS  NEXT.
TREY: GOOD EVENING THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US, I AM TREY
GOWDY, HAPPY EASTER.
WELCOME TO
"SUNDAY NIGHT IN AMERICA,"
WE START WITH THE BORDER,
WHICH REMAINS A CHAOTIC
CRISIS.
THERE ARE PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERNS, MANY ARE NOT HAPPY
WITH THE BORDER SITUATION,
THAT BECOMES A POLITICAL
CONCERN.
FOR DEMOCRATS HEADING TO
MIDTERMS.
>> IT HAS BEEN A
LONGSTANDING OPEN
INVITATION, ANY REPUBLICAN
THAT'S TO WORK WITH US ON
IMMIGRATION REFORM, YOU ARE
INVITED.
IT IS CLEAR WHAT WE'RE
SEEING FROM REPUBLICANS IS
AN EFFORT TO POLITICIZE THIS
AND NOT FIX WHAT WE ALL
RECOGNIZE AS AN OUTDATED AND
BROKEN SYSTEM.
TREY: AN OPEN INVITATION YOU
SAY?
LAST
INOUYE -- INVITATION
WAS IN 2020, FROM THEN
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP.
THEY HAD A HARD TIME FINDING
ANYONE THEY WANTED TO
DEPORT, NOW THEY CALL THE
SYSTEM BROKEN, AND THEY WANT
REPUBLICANS TO HELP FIX IT.
BUT DEMOCRACIES DON'T NEED
REPUBLICAN HELP, REMEMBER,
DEMOCRATS CONTROL THE HOUSE,
THE SENATE, AND THE WHITE
HOUSE.
THEY DON'T NEED LEGISLATIVE
HELP, THEY NEED POLITICAL
HELP, THEY NEED HELP
DEFLECTING THE BLAME FOR THE
CRISIS AT THE BORDER.
THE MATH IS SIMPLE, THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE SHOWING UP
AT THE BORDER IS HIGH.
IT WILL ONLY GET HIGHER IN
THE SPRING AND SUMMER
MONTHS.
THERE IS A WAR IN EASTERN
EUROPE, SOME OF THOSE
FLEEING THAT WAR WILL WIND
UP AT OUR BORDER,
DEMOCRATS USE THE
IMPLICATION AS A CAMPAIGN
ISSUE FOR YEARS.
WE'RE ALL SYMPATHETIC TO
THOSE SEEKS A BETTER LIFE,
AMERICA IS GENEROUS AND
WELCOMING, MORE SO THAN ANY
OTHER COUNTRY, MOST OF ALL
AMERICA IS A NATION OF LAWS,
RIGHT NOW, IT IS HARD TO SEE
THE LAW THROUGH THE CHAOS AT
THE BORDER, THERE WILL BE A
POLITICA